who is a third year student in our
health and clinical informatics PhD
program
Francis has a bachelor degree in
Biochemistry and cell biology as well as
a master's degree in bioscience and
health policy from Rice University in
Houston
she has participated in a wide range of
research from web bench to clinical
trials Health policy and most recently
worked on systematic reviews at the
Pacific Northwest EPC
she has always been drawn to cancer
research particularly the Precision
medicine and predictive analytic
initiatives her interest led her to
clinical informatics and she hopes that
her research will contribute to
responsible use of EHR data for research
give me a call
hi everyone thank you for attending
today today we'll be talking about
applying cause or imprints to real world
data
just a brief outline of today's
presentation first I'll go over the
motivation coming from the recent Trends
in healthcare and gaps when we do use
EHR data for research and then an
opportunity of applying causal inference
to when using ehrd for data for research
and lastly present a use case of a
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma to
investigate whether or not we could use
causal inference for EHR research
I'm sure that we are all aware of the
widespread EHR adoption in the U.S where
about 80 percent of office-based
Physicians and 90 of hospitals have
adopted some form of EHR although EHR
was not initially designed for research
purposes researchers are excited to use
this readily available vast amount of
data for research when traditional data
generation and collections are time
consuming and expensive and there's a
national shift from considering EHR data
for research as a secondary used to a
primary use in a living Health learning
Health System
this concept was originally proposed by
the National Academy of Medicine and now
promoted by the agency for healthcare
research and quality or art
in a learning Health System data
generated during Healthcare practice
such as EHR and administrative data are
used for research to generate evidence
that will inform future clinical
practice in a continuous feedback loop
the learning health system can help us
achieve the contribute aim of healthcare
which are to improve patient experience
improve population Health improve
clinician well-being and reduce cost
since the high-tech act there is a
steady increase in number of
Publications using EHR data this graph
is from a bibliometric study by jabali
and all and their research was executed
on November 2021 so the actual number of
Publications citations and cited
Publications are likely to be even
higher for 2021.
at the same time the number of machine
learning Publications has grown even
faster within the last five years many
machine learning research uses CHR data
such as forced clinical decision support
system
while this follows the learning Health
System model we should be cautious as
bad data or poor model specification
could lead to poor prediction such as
epic sepsis algorithm and some other
examples that I will go into
so despite the rise in popularity of
using EHR data for research many authors
appropriately cautioned that
observational data can only infer
Association not causation
but for a measured or omitted variables
can contribute to confounding bias for
these and other reasons suspicion in
machine learning and artificial
intelligence remains like observational
studies machine learning algorithms
identify variables associated with that
outcome not necessarily those in the
causal pathway
so let's talk about difference between
randomized control trials or rcts and
observational study
randomization minimizes confounding and
other types of biases providing
excellent internal validity which means
that we are confident in the causal
relationship being tested in experiment
and that the result is not likely to be
influenced by other factors
however they typically have a short
duration lasting up to one to two years
so long-term efficacy is unknown or
there's a high attrition and defining is
not as robust
for conditions where a most important
endpoint is many years down the road
from treatment such as cancer survival
clinical trials often use surrogate
endpoints that can be measured within
one to two years such as disease-free
survival but sometimes these surrogate
endpoints have not been validated to
truly reflect a benefit and survival or
quality of Health life
because of their high costs they usually
have relatively small sample size in the
hundreds which means they cannot conduct
subgroup analysis
rcts are often criticized for lack of
external
validity or Limited generalizability
it is estimated that less than 10
percent of cancer patients qualify for a
clinical trials
lastly rcts may not be feasible due to
ethical reasons or small patient
population to actually recruit for an
RCT
on the other hand these limitations of
rcts are Advantage advantages of
observational studies observational data
typically contain thousands to tens of
thousands of patients allowing for
subgroup analysis they also better
reflect real world setting and how well
the treatment actually work in the real
world
some observational data have long
follow-up
lastly a
the large population means it is more
suitable for rare Adverse Events where
you need a large amount of population to
observe these rare events
however observational data is
susceptible to biases
some databases especially when not set
up in a perspective data collection may
not contain all the details that the
researchers will like such as
performance status or comorbidity
in general observational studies agree
with rcts as you can see in these two
figures the top Dot and confidence
interval represent the poor estimate of
observational studies while the bottom
Point represents pulled estimate from
rcts the figure on the left represent
cardiologic treatments and the figure on
the right are non-cardiologic treatments
most of the pair occur on the same side
reaching similar conclusion although
there are a few where they diverge such
as here where rcts have no findings
rcts have no findings
but your observational studies suggests
one treatment is better than the other
and another another example here
so there are a few notable examples when
rcts and observational studies reached
conflicting conclusions that could lead
to Patient Harms in the 80s and 90s
physician studies that perimeter
possible women on hormone replacement
therapy showed lower rates of coronary
heart disease as seen in these two
Forest plots this prompted the women's
health initiative to initiate a
randomized control trial investigate
investigating hrt's effect on a variety
of diseases
but the trial was terminated early
because of interim analysis showing that
HRT actually increased the rate of
coronary heart disease VTE and invasive
breast cancer
more recently two meta-analyzes found
that about two-thirds of observational
studies do not agree with their
respective rcts using observational
studies based on National Registries
Sonia found no significant correlation
between clinical trials and
observational studies and only 62
percent of observational studies has a
ratio Falls within the 95 confidence
interval of randomized Trials
meanwhile kramar had all used a National
Cancer database to replicate clinical
trials mentioned by the national
Comprehensive Cancer Network clinical
practice guidelines for eight common
solid tumors
for each comparison they tested three
models a simple unit variate adjusted
multivariable and the propensity score
adjusted model
for a primary outcome of concordance
only 70 percent of multivariable models
and 64 percent of propensity score
adjusted models has a ratio of Falls
within the 95 confidence interval
reported by RCT
using a more crude assessment of p-value
only 61 of multivariable
ncdb analysis correctly favor the same
arm as the clinical trial and similarly
only 61 from the parenthesis scores
Justin model finds the same conclusion
and interestingly you have some that
actually favor the opposite arm as from
the clinical trial
on the other hand when clinical trials
finds no difference between treatment
arms about two-thirds of the
multivariable and propensity score
adjusted model actually found a
difference between treatment arms
some may suggest that because of the
larger population and observation
observational database they're more
likely to find small difference however
Sony had all investigated and found that
only 12 percent of studies that disagree
between observational studies and rcts
fall between 0.9 and 1.1 suggesting a
really small difference detected by a
large population
therefore the larger patient population
and observational data does not fully
account for the difference between rcts
and observational studies on cancer
treatments
now many smart people have learned about
potential reasons for this discrepancy
observed between rcts and observational
studies some are nicely summarized in
this table on the left by Franklin at
all first patient population may not be
accurately captured in real world data
so the underlying sample are different
between the two study designs
second treatment are usually tightly
controlled with frequent follow-ups to
ensure that patients are following the
protocol in reality patients are
typically less compliant with treatment
and lastly there could be difference in
outcome measure then that could be
affected by amount of missingness and
length of follow-up
additional potential reasons include
unadjusted confounding bias in
observational studies publication bias
for null findings are less likely to be
published in selection bias
now I've talked about bias several times
so that's really discussed what exactly
is bias bias is a systematic error in
the design conduct or analysis of a
study that results in a mistaken
estimate of an exposure's effect on the
risk of outcome note that this is a
systematic error not random error which
can be captured by statistical methods
such as confidence interval and
mitigated with larger samples population
on the other hand bias cannot be
mitigated with the larger sample
population because all data will be
skewed in the same way
so the first type of bias is selection
bias for only
selected patients are included this form
of bias can affect both rcts and
observational studies
for example
healthy younger patients are more likely
to be recruited in rcts while the true
patient population are likely to be
older and have more comorbidities
on the other hand health conscious
people are more likely to participate in
a cohort study on healthy lifestyle and
mortality known as volunteer or
self-selection bias
the second type of bias is information
bias which is a different measurement
error on how information are collected
and handled between comparison groups
this is more likely to occur in
observational studies for example users
with lower screen time tend to
overestimate their screen usage while
users with higher Springtime tend to get
underestimate their users so as a result
this reported information reduces the
true range of screen time usage and will
more likely lead to null findings
the last type of bias is confounding
bias caused by a confounder that causes
both the exposure and the outcome
this Factor results in this various
association between the exposure and
outcome or muscular true relation
in our earlier example of hormone
therapy and perimenopausal women
socioeconomic status and coronary artery
disease risk factors are potential
Compounders and adjust them for them
nullified the seemingly protective
effect of hormone therapy on
cardiovascular disease mortality
visiting this is an example illustrating
confounding bias in this meta-analysis
complaining comparing glucose lowering
drug gop1 with insulin rcts are shown in
the top and red while observational
studies are in the bottom in blue
so most of the rcts favors glp-1
or null findings and in contrast the
three blue open squares you see here
are unadjusted observational studies
that favor insulin so when you adjust
for confounders they're more likely to
favor gop1 much like their rcts
returning to our hormone therapy example
it appeared that confounding led to an
overestimate of the benefit in adjusting
for socioeconomic status and risk
factors attenuated the benefit
furthermore examining subgroups by age
and menopause onset suggested that
younger women benefit from hormone
therapy
this led to the hypothesis that estrogen
may be beneficial in healthy arteries a
singing younger woman
and interestingly in this case it is
possible that observational data's
longer follow-up may have introduced by
us as women who experience adverse
effects from hormone therapy are more
likely to discontinue it early on so the
cohort was skewed towards healthy women
who have continued on hormone therapy
for a long time
kind of opposite to confounding bias is
over adjustment bias so in this
situation A noun compounder is adjusted
for leading to a distortion of the
relation between exposure and outcome
for example In Obstetrics gestational
age is often adjusted for as a
confounder however it could be an
intermediate variable or a collider an
adjustment for it would mask the true
relation between the exposure and your
outcome
in this example
gestational age is likely an
intermediate variable between
preeclampsia and cerebral palsy in the
simple graph the solid line represents
women with preeclampsia and the dash
line represents those without
preeclampsia on their risk of cerebral
palsy based on gestational age
so as you can see it appears that women
with preeclampsia have a lower risk of
having children with cerebral palsy and
that is a little baffling
and that so when you adjust for
gestational age it appears that there is
a protective effect on cerebral palsy
which is not true
so what is likely true is that most of
the deleterious effect of preeclampsia
on cerebral palsy is mediated through
the shorter gestational age so when
gestational age is controlled for the
result is only the direct effect of
preeclampsia on cerebral palsy which may
be no
a more recently recognized type of bias
is social bias so in 2019 obermaid had
all found a case management referral
program algorithm that is less likely to
refer black patients for comparable
health status as white patients the
authors suggested that this bias arise
because algorithms predict health care
costs rather than
true Illness but unequal access to cure
means that we spend less money caring
for black patients than for white
patients or in other words a black
patient is likely sicker than their
white counterpart to incur their same
amount of healthcare cost the study
raised to important points first social
process May imprint bias onto data so
this should be evaluated for in future
and two variable selection is extremely
important sometimes surrogate Variables
answer a different question than the one
we're initially asked
there are some statistical methods that
allow observational studies to better
emulate RCT such as propensity score
analysis and inverse probability
weighting however there have been some
debate about the utility of propensity
score matching as we saw earlier in the
cancer treatment meta-analysis
propensity score model did not perform
better than multivariable model
so go in all suggested that
this is partially because propensity
score method heavily relies on model
assumptions and knowledge of the causal
mechanism to identify correct variables
to adjust for and taken into calculation
lastly there are likely new sources of
bias in EHR data in addition to biases
in traditional observational data such
as Registries and administrative
database
for example informative presence minus
means seek sticker patients generate
more data conversely healthier patients
are less likely to have health care
encounters so your data may be sparse or
not included in large academic health
centers for most research are generated
this type of different differential
information bias likely contributed to
the discrepancy between rcts and
observational studies on cardiovascular
benefits of bariatric surgery
so two observational studies using EHR
data suggest that a 40 to 50 percent
reduction in major adverse
cardiovascular events and patients
undergoing bariatric surgery but a small
preliminary RCT did not find any benefit
so retinol
went out to investigate this discrepancy
and they compare patients with bariatric
surgery to patients with hip or knee
arthroplasty and in that comparison they
did not find any cardiovascular benefits
like the RCT
the authors suggested that using an
active comparator group with comparable
Healthcare encounters nullified the
cardiovascular benefits of bariatric
surgery
my preliminary literature literature
search only identified two potential
good Frameworks for evaluating biases in
EHR data but no systematic review
the framework on the left here by
Terrace at all identifies where bias
could occur in the healthcare process
meanwhile or hey the Dutch group was
funded by the European commission to
develop a core information architecture
for the European learning Health System
primarily based on EHR data their
framework captures the entire data
pipeline from data generation and during
clinical practice to storage and
database and extraction for research
these are good foundational Frameworks
but do not highlight specific biases
that researchers should be aware of
the lack of systematic review is
problematic because there are lesser
known biases in the informatics
literature that have substantial
consequence on analysis we have already
seen over adjustment and social bias so
now I'll mention collided buyers a
collider is caused by the exposure and
outcome independently in contrast to
confounder of just adjusting for a
collider distorts the relation between
exposure and outcome and you could cause
a spurious relation
and in progress review by Nicole and
Chrissy found that only three
Publications in 10 informatics journals
searched that contained the term
collider bias showing how
less represented it is in the
informatics literature
confounded by indication occurs when an
indication such as heart disease caused
the outcome
such a stroke that is also associated
with the exposure such as aspirin use
and Immortal time bias refers to a time
period introduced by the study design
where the patients aren't Immortal this
bias tends to exaggerate the
effectiveness of drugs by creating a
survival Advantage for the exposed
patients so in this example Patient 2
that in this example that requires
filling two prescriptions for aspirin in
order to be classified as an aspirin
users patient number two has an immortal
time here between diagnosis and when
they first fill their aspirin
prescription so this time is mistakenly
attributed to a benefit of aspirin when
the patient is not really under the
treatment of aspirin
and misclassification bias is
really prevalent and yes it could be
prevalent in ehr2 as you can see here so
for patients who do not have the disease
but are being
worked up to roll out the disease may be
mistakenly captured as having the
disease on the other hand
patients seeking care Elsewhere for the
disease who might actually have the
disease but that is not documented in
this particular institution's EHR will
then be misclassified as not having the
disease
so to quickly summarize there are
several known issues with using EHR data
for clinical research
number one is inappropriate adjustments
such as over adjusting or collided bias
there are hidden social biases and data
as a result of the healthcare process
and a lack of catalog of bias specific
to EHR data
so to better emulate rct's clinical
research informatics needs to identify
and catalog biases in EHR data and
address them appropriately
so I'm proposing that causal inference
is a potential solution to better
utilize EHR data for solution for
research
one of the founding fathers of this
field is Judea Pearl and he defines it
as an extra statistical method that can
be used to express and interpret causal
assumptions
and a better definition is an
intellectual discipline that considers
the assumptions study designs and
estimation strategies that allow
researchers to draw cause or conclusions
Based on data
I want to point out that in causal
inference we are interested in
causations so we're interested in this
counterfactual framework of what if
everyone is treated versus what if
everyone is not treated this is
different from Association where we're
studying what is the risk of outcome in
people who are treated versus the risk
of outcome in people who are not treated
a causal model represents the mechanism
by which data are generated structural
causal model is a way of describing the
relevant features of the world and how
they interact with each other
this is a
directed acyclic graph directed means
the arrows represent how one variable is
a cause for another variable and acyclic
meaning you cannot have a cycle that
goes back to this variable
and the dag represents unstated
relationships between variables as
States explicitly so we can inform
readers the choice of which variables we
are collecting it helps us differentiate
confounders from mediators
and therefore determine what variables
to control for
and I explains and identify selection
bias and it supports effective
communication between researchers
so I'll briefly go over what those each
one of those middle variables mean
to start a confounder we have talked
about is a common cause of treatment
path
of treatment and outcome but not on the
causal pathway
so for example
age is a confounder in the relationship
between exercise and cholesterol
if you look at this graph you say oh
great extra more exercise increases my
cholesterol level so I should not
exercise but we're not we're ignoring
the age confounder here where age is
related the older you are the more
likely you will exercise but also you're
more likely to have higher cholesterol
level So within each age group exercise
still reduces your cholesterol level
a mediator or intermediate variable is
as affected by the exposure and effects
to outcome
so in our earlier example
a maternal age is
likely going to affect your chance of
preeclampsia which will also then affect
your chance of cerebral palsy
an effect modifier moderates the average
causal effect of exposure on outcome for
example sex often included as a
confounder is more likely to be an
effect modifier
so for example in this drug that
increases your HDL level it is highly
effective in men but not so much in
women so depending on your study
composition this drug could appear as if
there is no effect on your HDL level
when in fact it is really beneficial for
men
a collider is a variable caused by both
exposure and outcome collider bios is a
serious association between exposure and
outcome when conditioning on their
common effect this Collider
selection bias is an association between
exposure and outcome created as a result
of the process by which individuals are
selected into the analysis
some selection bias is a form of
collider bias if the selection factor is
a collider so in this example locomotor
disease and respiratory disease the
relation between them if you condition
on using an inpatient population EHR
data then you might generate the
spurious relations because patients with
locomotor disease are likely to be
hospitalized at the same time
respiratory disease patients are more
likely to be hospitalized
so it appears as if there is a relations
between these two disease when there is
probably not
so direct to the acyclic graph encodes
domain knowledge and assumptions to
guide analysis
traditional statistical definition of a
compounder is a variable that is
associated with exposure and outcome and
does not lie on the causal pathway which
would indicate a mediator
however where the error points help us
distinguish between a confounder and a
Collider
so these are various ways of
representing what is the potential
causal mechanism between preeclampsia
and cerebral palsy and if gestational
age is uh
secondary to abruption
so there are three main assumptions when
applying causal inference to
observational data these are complex
Concepts but I just want to point out
these assumptions are important to make
observational studies more similar to
rcts and the field recognizes that these
are strong assumptions so first is
exchangeability or the risk of outcome
in group a is the same as risk of
outcome in group b had Group B we see
the same treatment as given to group a
and positivity the probability of
receiving every value of treatment is
greater than zero in other words
everyone should have some non-zero
probability of receiving the
intervention this is important
particularly when using propensity score
matching where inverse probability
weighting but not just for propensity
scores because to emulate an RCT
everyone can be randomized to either
group in the RCT
the last assumption is consistency or
values of exposed
exposure corresponds to well-defined
interventions in other words we need to
be able to explain how a certain level
of exposure could be hypothetically
assigned to
uh person with a different exposure with
a different exposure level so consider
how would you assign a healthy BMI of
less than 25 it is you can't just
randomly magically make someone
just BMI under 25 so that is not a good
exposure to study rather a better
intervention exposure to study would be
exercise intervention to achieve a
healthier BMI or a weight loss drug
and that leads me to my research
question is how can we improve inference
from EHR data when rcts are not feasible
or available
hypothesizing that a causal framework
using EHR data with appropriate bias
adjustment will yell results closer to
rcts
and briefly there's three specific aims
are one to synthesize biases unique to
EHR data to identify pdac treatment
decision process that contributes to
Patient selection for either treatment
pathway and three to construct a causal
model emulating the priapank1 trial to
include bias variables from game one and
patient selection factors from aim2 and
internally validate the model
briefly just touching upon the use case
of pancreatic cancer it is ranked 10th
in incidence but third in mortality in
the U.S at the time of diagnosis most
people are in the metastatic stage or
stage four and that has a really poor
five-year survival less than three
percent
pancreatic duct adenocarcmonoma or pdac
accounts for 85 percent of pancreatic
cancer so it is the most prevalent kind
and about 15 to 20 percent of patients
with pdac have respectable disease
there are some risk factors for pdac but
even in family in people with family
history of adac only about 50 of them
would actually have pdac
other risk factors include chronic
pancreatitis pancreatic cysts tobacco
smoking obesity and diabetes
symptoms for a pink pdac are
not very specific and contribute to
their delayed diagnosis by at least
about two months
are the two treatment Pathways so just
recommended in the clinical practice
guideline by nccn so the top is
respectable disease patients with the
best prognosis and the bottom is
borderline resectable disease people who
can still undergo surgery
I highlighted these two boxes here that
recommends new adjuvant therapy but the
true utility of new attribute therapy is
not really well known so to talk about
new adjuvant therapy refers to
systematic systemic
chemo or radiation therapy given before
a surgery as opposed to azurement
therapy which is given after the surgery
the thought is that after undergoing
this massive surgical procedure only 50
of patients can receive adjuvant therapy
due to poor performance status or
discovery of metastasis while the
patient is recovering from their surgery
so instead by giving them systemic
therapy up front 100 of the patient
population can receive this therapy and
likely to treat micro metastases Neo
azurement therapy may also improve the
likelihood of a negative margin
resection which is associated with
improved survival
and also during neoadjiment therapy
patients with more rapidly Progressive
disease can be identified and spared of
a long surgery that would not likely be
beneficial
so in one of my previously mentioned
meta-analysis comparing rcts and
observational studies about two-thirds
of pancreatic cancer treatment pairs or
concordant were consistent with each
other with the RCT
and that is generally in line with about
two-thirds of cancer treatments are
concordant between rcts and our
observational studies
as we saw earlier the nccn recommends
considering neoadiment therapy prior to
surgery but true Effectiveness is not
clear-cut
so this is based on a first some
observational studies published in 2016
suggesting a benefit of neoadjupin
therapy compared to surgery first
but a separate observational studies
find no benefits
and a small RCT is also find no benefit
so it appears that we're leaning towards
there is no difference
and because of the relatively small
population of pancreatic cancer two
German trials were actually terminated
early due to low recruitment
until finally in 2020 the Dutch team
conducted a finished a prio pinkmont
trial and they found no significant
difference except maybe some benefit in
more advanced borderline respectable
patients
so it seems like this might be resolved
until very recently in 2022 the same
team came back and found there is
actually a difference and you know after
event therapy is better than surgery
first and a really long-term follow-up
of almost five years
so if you're like me I'm still a little
not sure which site is better I if I
have the disease today I don't know
whether or not I want to go with the
more aggressive new azurement up front
have the surgery and Asthma therapy
after or just after surgery first
so in conclusion applying causal
inference to model pdac patients ESR
data could better emulate rcts
pancreatic cancer has a high mortality
rate and incidence is rising
however the relatively no number of
patients make it difficult to recruit
patients for clinical trials so patients
and clinicians rely on observational
studies to inform treatment decision
making
when trial becomes available sometimes
it conflicts with previous observational
studies
ahr data offers potentially more
granular data than current registry such
as Seer and ncdb that could supplement
evidence based in the absence of trial
data
recognizing biases in EHR data allows
researchers to better mitigate them
so using a causal inference tools and
concept to model patient outcomes could
fill in an Evidence Gap and generate
worthy hypothesis for future rcts
it is estimated that we have about 3 000
pancreatic cancer in the Oregon State
cancer registry and about 600 to 1300
surgeries have been conducted at OHSU so
we assume that this could be possible
feasible with just OHSU patient data
and finally I would just like to
acknowledge the mentors
shown here and the my students former
and current and demise other faculty and
staff and the support from the National
Library of Medicine
and I'll be happy to take any questions
were you able to see questions if they
come in on that
uh
I can try
you might need to stop sharing yeah
I like that
um hey Francis can you hear me
hi is this adip yeah
I have a quick question and and we
discussed this earlier I think
um but one of the major limitations of
this causal inference approach is
um the unobserved confounders
and if you're trying to model that
uh like how are you going to handle that
in EHR data
I'm sorry I didn't hear the first half
model Compounders on unobserved
confounders
unobserved confounders yes that is the a
really great question and my previous
answer was to look at
um surrogate variables which I know I've
just mentioned that Sugar variables are
not great
um
I put up a slide there is one potential
method of using an e value to see how
much does an unmeasured confounder
affect your relations and how how great
is this confounder's influence to change
your conclusion and
I think it's a useful tool but there's
some debate to whether or not it is
useful so I think I would still like to
include this e-value to account for what
is the potentially one single I'll
measure confounder's influence on the
result
sounds good thank you Francis thank you
so if you you mentioned cases where the
observational study May contradicts the
clinical trial uh just looking at the
effect size of our help you kind of
decide which one you should Place more
weight on
some interesting questions so I
think clinicians more likely are going
to trust the trial data and personally I
would say a meta-analysis of all of your
rcts and combine it with your
observational data that might be most
useful to see where
um get you closer to the truth so one
child is not definitive
hi this is Karen I have a question for
you
um and this is and maybe there's some um
clinical expertise here that can answer
this how much Choice do patients have in
this process I mean is it is does your
clinician or your surgeon dictate this
or do you have actual
is there a choice does a patient have
have a choice in some of this
I think I don't know if we have have a
clinician on who could help with that is
Emerson going to help us with that
Emerson Chan I'm a gynecologist
um I think
um
a lot I mean there are some occasionally
there are some patients
um that might have certain preferences
and and it kind of comes out in some of
the discussion and decision
um but I feel like
a provider dictated
surgeon or from the medical oncologist
um and that actually goes to my next
question
um is
um Francis are you more interested in
um whether you know we should be doing
giving neoadjuvant chemotherapy based on
some of the retrospective steps that
happen or some of the
um early trials sign or are you more
interested in understanding
factors that determine whether someone
should get new adjuvant therapy you know
maybe based on people based on provider
thinking other risk
uh
um what do you think is
either interesting or more feasible in
looking at each job
thank you that is a hard question and
these two are sound similar but I get I
get it that there are ultimately
different so your one is understanding
is new adjuvant better than Azure wind
or just comparing which one is better
versus
um what kind of patients would benefit
from neo-ashment therapy
I think what I'm proposing first is to
study the first question is just to
really try to model
um how does the HR data compare to rcts
when they when we are trying to answer
the same questions and the patient
factors why I'm interested in that is
because they could potentially be
confounders or they should be included
in your inverse probably waiting to see
how patients assort into either
treatment pathways
does that answer your question
yeah yeah that's I mean um yeah there
are two very different products I'm not
very different but the different
projects that
um just probably would approaches
um even though the propane trial is kind
of what is available that we can always
compare to and lots of updates
there is a different clinical trial that
is currently outgoing that's
specifically good times one arm getting
new adjuvan and the other are getting
the same chemo afterwards but that study
won't be completed probably for another
few years but that certainly will be
something in the future that
um one can one can see you know is that
are some of the observational studies
um
correct or is it or
um or is that uh
or does the randomized trials say
something else in the future
I have a question about your first name
if I could jump in there um this is Eric
uh first of all great job I think you
did an excellent job
um covering some kind of complex
um causal inference you know models and
terminology and and different types of
biases in a short time I think that was
great
um but I was just curious about so you
know your your first name you you list
as synthesizing biases unique to EHR
data and I know you're gonna
um kind of explore this through this
this case study here but I was just
wondering if you could talk a little bit
more about kind of your your goal for
that aim and the process you'll you'll
take to do it because I think as you
alluded to here there could be great
value in having like a larger
application of
um being able to understand just biases
that are inherent to EHR data in the
field and that can be applied to other
cases and so I just see I was curious
about how you kind of plan to approach
that first one is it specific to This
research question is it from a larger
perspective and what's your your process
going to be for thinking about that
yeah so the first name will not be
specific to just this use case um I'm
envisioning as a more comprehensive
search so it will be following a more
traditional systematic review
protocol where I set up my picot and
have dual reviewers and the question to
cast is for all studies on EHR data what
have people identified as biases in in
the EHR data and compare that to
biases that we have known from other
observational data sources so this would
be like uh I'm hoping for it to be a
more comprehensive capture of data
a biases
okay great cool yeah I think that would
be
um you know very useful for sure
and I'm happy to talk with you about it
as you embark on that road
and um are there any other questions and
if not just if the folks who are part of
francis's Symposium committee could
stick around for a little bit afterwards
nice work Francis
thank you
lots of hand clapping I I don't know if
you can see it there but there's lots of
uh hand clapping going on
and Karen do you have a few minutes to
stick around as well I can great thank
you